[Music]
wonderful I mean added credit Patti
LuPone reprising her show-stopping
number from Andrew Lloyd Webber's Evita
at the 61st Grammy Awards Lloyd Webber
is known for some of Broadway's biggest
hits along with Evita
he's the composer behind Jesus Christ
Superstar cats and the Phantom of the
Opera
Jamie wax caught up with Lloyd Webber
just yesterday ahead of this weekend's
Tony Awards Jamie good morning good
morning Vlad that's right tomorrow night
Andrew Lloyd Webber will receive his
seventh Tony Award this time a special
one for lifetime achievement in the
theater
along with Chita Rivera I spoke with him
about that and his remarkable career you
celebrated your 70th birthday this year
which is hard to believe yes it's very
hard to believe I can't believe that I'm
17 I guess I saw the procedure of God
more energy at the moment that I think I
can ever remember you are bubbling over
with energy well yeah well I don't know
is just doing I'm desperately wanting to
find a new show to write I can't find
this subject at the moment very annoying
because you know they're thinking about
musicals is is that a great story can
really really carry an awful lot a good
score can't necessarily sustain a bad
story
[Music]
Andrew Lloyd Webber has been composing
two great stories for over five decades
when you look at the diverse subject
matter of the 13 musicals you've
composed what is it about a story that
grabs you is there a unifying theme well
I don't think there's a necessarily
unifying theme and of course somebody is
going to immediately say well he's
talking rubbish because what about cats
that doesn't have a story but I always
say cats is the kind of exception that
proves the rule really in the end it's
got to have something that I think
audiences you know relate to and in fact
there are very very few stories we're
speaking right after the tremendous
success of Jesus Christ Superstar alive
well exceeded the expectations I would
say did you have expectations as I well
I was very excited about it when I said
look guys if we're gonna do it please
can I beg one thing that we try and keep
the rock ingredient really at its center
because I always thought that Jesus
Christ Superstar was written for various
reasons as an album first but really
because nobody wanted to produce it in
the theater I kind of feel that to do it
closer to a stage concert is the way
forward and that's what they did we are
on the stage at the Winter Garden
Theatre where one of the most
groundbreaking musical theatre designs
ever happened with cats and now the
stage is not inhabited by cats but by
incredibly talented young people who
play their own instruments every night
well I think the thing about school of
rock which attracted me to it is it's
about the empowering force of music for
children I mean I am passionate about
music in education it's not about
turning kids into musicians necessarily
well that's nice if they are Arco they
do become but it changes behavior it
changes attitudes and I've seen it
happen there is a value to notes and a
rhythm and the other it it kind of
spills off into all of these other areas
in fact his breakthrough musical was
written for an English boys school along
with lyricist Tim Rice when you're
writing Joseph and the Amazing
Technicolor Dreamcoat for us a school
choir did the two of you ever dream a
future like you've had I don't know I
mean Tim was ice
pose possibly less kind of obsessed with
musical theater than I was but I guess
the answer is of course no I I mean when
I think of the little school concert on
a Friday afternoon in the rain with
bored parents thinking we want to get
home let's get out of here before the
rush hour and then thinking to where I
am now I I can't believe it so every
time you come back here do you feel that
energy that you talk about oh absolutely
Lloyd Webber is back in New York for
tomorrow night's Tony Awards must have
gone 40 melodies at the moment probably
none of them will get hurt the composer
is a six-time Tony winner we are deeply
honored including his 1988 win for the
Phantom of the Opera now in its 31st
year the show's run is the longest in
Broadway history when you think about
the longevity of Phantom of the Opera
does that surprise even you do you know
what I'm not surprised
actually any more than I'm surprised
when I go and see lon King you know
which I mean I saw a couple of months
ago it's one of those rare moments where
absolutely everything comes together it
doesn't happen very often in the musical
I mean phantom obviously LAN King and
it's done it done it with Hamilton you
know it's just where every single
ingredient from design choreography
direction music and they all mesh into
one extraordinary hole why is it so rare
that that magic happens where everything
gels I wish I could tell you you've
received so many titles and accolades
this weekend do you receive a very
special one from the Broadway community
a Lifetime Achievement Award is this one
special to you well I have to say I
think he probably is
the special one Broadway is that I'm a
musical theater and to receive Addison
bridge is something that I could never
have dreamt old in his recent memoir
unmasked Lloyd Webber touches on his
struggles in the past with health issues
and even depression but I'll tell you
having sat down with him a few times
over the past few years he's not kidding
about that new energy he's got he's got
something going on maybe he has
something up his sleeve for us in the
next chapter I hope so
what doesn't want the next answer
whenever everybody does and one out it I
haven't met him as much as you but the
one time I did it was so hard for me to
not be like so that line you know my
power over you grows stronger yet where
did you get that from and he was like
calm down he's like how many times have
you seen phantom I'm like a lot I've
made you a very rich exactly many times
Jamie thank you so much thanks so much
cheese you can watch a 72nd annual Tony
Awards hosted by Josh Groban and Sara
Bareilles right here on CBS
it all starts tomorrow night at 8:00
7:00 central